[Music]
in 1985 three researchers on a dolphin
studying expedition got a little bored
to lighten things up one pretended to be
Poseidon by placing a seaweed garland on
his head and then throwing it into the
ocean moments later a dolphin surfaced
with the seaweed crowning her head sure
this could have been a coincidence but
it's also entirely possible that the
dolphin was mimicking the scientist
that's because dolphins are one of the
smartest animal species on earth so
exactly how smart are they like whales
and porpoises dolphins belong to the
group of aquatic mammals known as
cetaceans who comprise 86 different
species and share a common link with
ungulates or hoofed animals originally
land mammals the first cetaceans entered
the water about 55 million years ago as
large predators with sharp teeth then a
shift in ocean temperatures about 35
million years ago reduced the
availability of prey
one group of cetaceans who survived this
disruption the Adhan tiss eats wound up
smaller with less sharp teeth but also
larger and more complex brains that
allowed for complex social relationships
as well as echolocation to navigate and
communicate jump ahead to the present
and modern dolphins brains are so large
that their encephalization quotient
their brain size compared to the average
for their body size is second only to
humans dolphins have evolved to survive
through their ability to form complex
social networks that hunt ward off
rivals and raise offspring together for
example one group of Florida dolphins
practices a sophisticated form of
cooperation to hunt fish a dolphin
designated as the net maker kicks up mud
while another gives the signal for the
other dolphins to simultaneously line up
and catch the escaping fish
achieving a goal like this requires
deliberate planning and cooperation
which in turn requires some form of
intentional communication dolphins
passed down their communication methods
and other skills from generation to
generation different dolphin populations
exhibit variations in greetings hunting
strategies and other behaviors this sort
of cultural transmission even extends to
tool use one group of bottlenose
dolphins off the Australian coast
nicknamed the dolphin sponge Club has
learned how to cover their rostrums with
sponges
when rooting in sharp corals passing the
knowledge from mother to daughter
dolphins have even demonstrated language
comprehension
when taught a language based on whistles
and hand gestures they not only
understood what the signals meant but
that their order had meaning
the difference between bringing the ball
to the heap and bringing the hoop to the
ball so they were able to process two of
the main elements of human language
symbols that stand for objects and
actions and syntax that governs how they
are structured dolphins are also one of
the few species who pass the mirror test
by recognizing themselves in mirrors
they indicate physical self awareness
and research shows they can recognize
not just their bodies but also their own
thoughts a property called metacognition
in one study dolphins comparing two
sounds could indicate the same different
or uncertain response just like humans
they indicated uncertainty more often
with difficult trials suggesting they're
aware of what they know and how
confident they feel about that knowledge
but some of the most amazing things
about dolphins are their senses of
empathy
altruism and attachment the habit of
helping injured individuals extends
across the species barrier as evidenced
by the many accounts of dolphins
carrying humans to the surface to
breathe and like us
dolphins mourn their dead when we
consider all the evidence we may wonder
why humans still hunt dolphins for meat
endanger them through fishing and
pollution or imprison them too
form tricks the ultimate question may
not be whether dolphins are intelligent
and complex beings but whether humans
can empathize with them enough to keep
them safe and free
Oh
[Music]